I'm not doing well I'm sick
Shaquille O'Neal reeling from the news
of Kobe Bryant's death during the big
podcast with Shaq on Monday
sad enough you hear his daughters with
them I didn't do anything I haven't even
slept Bryant his 13 year old daughter
Gianna and seven others died in a
helicopter crash in Calabasas California
Sunday morning I was downstairs working
I wish you care and my other son Greg
showed me the Tian's in Cleveland and I
yelled at Greg
so y'all might get that by my face get
it off my face because you know how the
Internet hoax and all that you know I
figure somebody was just playing around
so just I'm working out wish you care
didn't want to believe it
what's more the retired basketball star
says the news triggered the same awful
emotions he's been struggling with since
his sister Aisha died of cancer in
October and I haven't been sleeping
after ayisha's death because of just you
know not thinking about just a good time
but thinking about this times when I
could have did something or I could have
said something
what could I did something different I
could have loved them more or I could
have showed them more support and the
same thing hit when I found out this
news of course Shaq and Kobe famously
feuded in the past but they've remained
close in recent years this one guard for
a long time I have a little brother but
I really lost a brother yesterday Shaq
also shared several tributes to the
Black Mamba on social media
no way possible you know just a blessing
from above LeBron James took the
Instagram to pay his respects to posting
a series of photos alongside a caption
that begins I'm not ready but here I go
the Lakers star continued quote I
literally just heard your voice Sunday
didn't think for one bit in a million
years that would be the last
conversation we'd have LeBron also vowed
to carry on Kobe's legacy writing it's
my responsibility to put this on my back
and keep it going
LeBron was seen arriving at LAX with his
teammates hours after the crash on
Sunday they were all crying and hugging
friends the night before
Kobe praised LeBron for surpassing him
on the NBA's all-time scoring list and
when it came time to write the final
chapter of his NBA career
Kobe saved one of his most unforgettable
performances for last
sixteen point six zero man
to spend 20 years here you can't write
something better than this
the MBA released their own touching
tribute to Bryant after their decision
to postpone Tuesday's Lakers Clippers
game in the wake of his death a source
close to the Lakers tells et that the
league made the right call quote it's
not just the players hurting Kobe was
here for two decades and is like family
to everyone in the building
no one is okay the source adds that the
team brought in grief counselors who
will be available to employees and
players for the foreseeable future
however there's no information on a
memorial or funeral quite yet beloved by
fans around the world Kobe Bryant had
transcended the game he embodied
excellence achievement and aspiration
for millions of fans everywhere
[Music]
and millions of athletes for that matter
like tennis champ Novak Djokovic who
were Kobe's initials and his jersey
numbers on his jacket during the
Australian Open Novak got emotional when
he was asked about how much the black
mamba inspired him he was my mentor my
friend and it's just heartbreaking to
see and to hear what has happened to him
and his daughter the most important
thing is how your career moves and
touches those around you and how it
carries forward to the next generation
[Music]
you